en plus des incendies les pompiers
premiers répondants sont formés pour
intervenir dans des cas d'arrêt cardio
respiratoire ou d'urgence médicale ils
sont donc plus exposés à des scènes
traumatisantes
je les compte plus combien de parents du
j'ai décroché je compte plus combien de
personnes âgées dans des conditions
atroces qu'on a trouvé qu'ils étaient
dans la même semaine j'ai assisté une
femme d'être au monde un enfant est dans
la même semaine de travail
j'irai à nîmes et un enfant qui étaient
dans son berceau j'ai tenté de le
réanimer jusque dans la salle d'urgence
afin de céder je trouve une personne
dupe en train de se faire manger par
vichy il ya trois ans ce pop y ait subi
un choc post traumatique après avoir vu
le jeune mourir lors d'une intervention
dans le métro de montréal
l'accumulation les gens de la carapace
dure de l'armée
il est d'avoir en a parlé d'avoir à
l'aneth c'est difficile d'admettre leur
dire on a un milieu hyper orgueilleux
les premiers répondants qui désire
garder l'anonymat pour ne pas nuire à
son dossier a dû poser un genou par
terre
il a été en arrêt de travail durant six
mois et déplore avoir eu à se battre
avec la commission des normes de
l'équité de la santé de la sécurité du
travail pour faire reconnaître sa
condition si je me fracturé le tibia
lors d'un incendie
c'est visible d'une radiographie qui
vont vouloir le témoigner alors que dans
un code un choc post traumatique g a
justifié qu'est ce qui s'est produit
gr expliquer cette histoire là à
plusieurs reprises le processus
administratif lié à l'accident de
travail bien poésie processus de
guérison des dossiers comme cela il y en
a de plus en plus selon des données
obtenues par radio-canada le nombre de
choc post traumatique chez les pompiers
montréalais est passé de 6 en 2013 à 22
en 2018
il a donc plus que triplé en cinq ans 22
qui ont levé la main
c'est ça ne dénombre pas ceux qui
souffrent en silence actuellement qu'on
considérait trop bien plus élevé que ça
radio canada a appris que c'est entre
autres pour cette raison que le
regroupement des associations des
pompiers du québec rencontrera le
cabinet du ministre du travail lundi à
québec le regroupement souhaite
notamment faire reconnaître le choc post
traumatique comme l'assurent
professionnels
aucune blessure psychologique n'est
reconnue ou n'y a pas de présomption qui
s'applique en la faveur des gens qui ont
des maladies professionnelles au niveau
psychologique
la loi sur les accidents du travail et
les maladies professionnelles date de
le ministre du travail jean boulet
veulent a modifié en raison de son
caractère désuet la cnss était pour sa
part ne pas répondu à nos questions
et si marie laurence de l'année radio
canada montréal